he got in a lot of fights he got in
fights at his gas station there was a
guy that uh who was a rival gas station
owner who came by and painted over his
sign and so he uh he painted it back the
way it should be and the guy came by to
paint it again so Colonel and one of the
Shell Oil Executives chased the guy down
the street and shot at him uh and ended
up the other guy shot and killed him
Colonel didn't kill him but uh yeah
killed this competition oh my God crazy
really if if he actually shot guy we
wouldn't have KFC
right I mean he also there was another
time where he was in his shop and
somebody fired a gun on the street and
some kind of argument so he ran out he
was in his underwear for reasons I I'm
not exactly sure but he ran out with his
shotgun and he held the guys in his
while he was in his underwear and then
helped the police arrest them when they
got there I reckon he would have had the
Big W on the way C